xenon here is my credit card and you are
currently inside
a scale replica of a gamestop you can
grab
as many items as you want but if you go
over the limit of my credit card
you have to put it back oh yeah i'll
snag that that's 450.
okay i'll grab the place eleven hundred
dollars can i tell you a secret xenon if
you bought
everything in this store it'd be below
the limit but now that i've told you
that
you have 15 seconds go oh george with a
ps5 you know everyone needs one
he's much less picky now huh playstation
gift card
congratulations you bought every single
item in a gamestop
but now why is there this obstacle
course of death
right outside this beautiful game stop
who wouldn't shop here
if you finish this course i will order
all those items to your house today
but if you die you get nothing let's go
xenon
okay i got this i win these could be
traps you know there definitely are
traps
uh-oh uh-oh row row row i'm good
he's a 21st century girl he's fine we
got zombies now okay
hey xenon turn around there's a
playstation 5. oh no
get the ps5 oh
okay he was almost the first person in
history to die
for playstation 5. maybe not actually
okay look look
skeletons be aware this looks close to
impossible i gotta time this
you should probably reset all the
zombies oh no
no no this is why i like gaming channel
it's to the death
chris heal him give him some help chris
oh chris
okay i'm good all right he's going i
want to make sure my little fox oh
god girl put down a ladder all right i
can't place box
i'm good nothing happening let's go okay
just don't fall here this is where i
fell
okay i'm good oh you're good you you
don't suck anymore oh my god look at
your
left on the right behind you go
you're so close go oh
oh he almost fell played in slow-mo
congratulations xenon on winning all
these items big seed
do you see this walmart behind you yeah
i see this walmart it is full of tons of
cool items like lawnmowers
electronics clothes anything and
everything you could ever want
and anything you grab you can keep
there's just a giant mecca that's gonna
be trying to kill you the entire time
oh my god don't worry about it if it
kills you you walk away with nothing
i'm ready begin go big she go
no you didn't see me uh let me just grab
all this really quickly oh you're so bad
yep just going to grab a ring get the tv
get the tv
go go go go go go yeah yeah yeah he
can't turn
yes let's go that's it you're going down
imagine if we did this video in real
life i think i would die and realize
that i don't know about that one oh i
have you cornered
hikaru get out of my way go big c
go big z oh it's gonna be for nothing
fix it
no yeah
you killed big c oh my god no
you lost a grill a couch a lawnmower
thank you for coming out next door
chris lost this video and his punishment
is he has to film the next video with a
pb
j on his head which do you want first
the peanut butter or the jelly jelly
first
peanut butter oh it's okay
bread on my head and now that chris has
bread on his head
gentlemen at the end of this obstacle
course
is the zoomies that conveniently sells
our merch whichever one of you makes it
to that zoomies first i'll let you buy
whatever you want
server drop the game go go go oh no
oh don't let poppy win his skin's so
gross
oh oh
oh we've got to go all the way back
oh bounce acrylics killing it oh
acrylic doesn't want free zoomies
there it is there it is nice the kakashi
skin fits you
and we in we're in the next round
acrylic is catching up come back time
freaking fear said i have no freaking
fear because i'm about to get all this
zoomies merch
acrylics now on the ice zone
never mind acrylic wants fear to win i
guess we're going through i can see
zoomies in my reach will you make it
no way fear fear fear look at that store
right there
it's so close i can feel it oh let's
go oh my god all right
fear welcome to zoomies you can buy
whatever you want but you only have 30
seconds
go oh zoomies typically has a bunch of
other clothes but
no one wants those clothes so i just got
rid of all of it except for our merch
yeah get the gaming merch get the gaming
there's a gaming hoodie over here two
one oh congrats fear
you got a bunch of hoodies chainsaw and
bronzy at the end of this
obstacle course is a full-scale replica
of a best spy whoever finishes this
obstacle course first gets to go into
that best buy with my credit card and
buy whatever they want
you're going down server drop the gates
race the best buy you might just eat my
dust eat my dog no you eat my
this is kind of like black friday but
like extreme blacks right
away i'm talking about oh chainsaw
oh yes yeah i told you
oh chase out takes the lead oh chase now
you're going down
oh oh don't chainsaw made a mistake
you're going down chainsaw you're going
down
all right now the maze of cacti
oh they go through the maze of cacti at
the same time this is so close
you might not see my dust
die server turn on pvp
stay down there no i won't let you in
get off
no no oh
let's go chase up i'm gonna win
no messed up you're gonna mess up he did
chase song that was your chance chainsaw
what are you doing
just jump like a living chainsaw i'm
jumping right away
yellow yeah
chainsaw see that best buy in front of
you land in that hole
to go shop i'm not good with this let's
go
[Music]
i can't bring my second one i think
brunch is a circuit city kind of guy
chainsides right on your tail you gotta
go for best buy
how does this make you feel sad yeah i
would too bye
i just rolled a pair of dice and that
pair of dice dictated the limit on my
credit card if you go over the limit you
get
nothing i brought myself here hello i'm
sister
what is that it's a gaming desktop
that's a 400
computer get that bread up i don't have
apple i do
hey get it for your sister hey grab
another one what do you hate your sister
bronzy
yes oh that's a nice gaming monitor
right there
oh i do need a monitor yo do you have a
ps5 there's a ps5 over here
twenty four hundred dollars twenty four
hundred twenty six hundred whoa that's a
4k
55 inch that is approximately seventeen
hundred dollars
there is a limit on this credit card and
i think i'm gonna check out sir once you
throw everything here you're done
all right congrats bronzy on all the
items the limit on the card was 7
000. oh my god you're so good bronzy
what do you have to say to the world
thank you mr beast thank you to my
sister for helping me
hi guys if you haven't already hit that
subscribe button we're closing about 20
million subscribers make me so happy see
in the next video